last time in the good Star Trek movie
nothing that really connects to this one
so bucket
and now the next generation team takes
over the plots that don't make sense
this is Star Trek generations
Star Trek The Next Generation was a big
hit on TV for years but in their first
motion picture ride out we got a pretty
unbalanced pretty nonsensical and at
times pretty annoying series of subplots
that often result in this reaction by
hippies so that's not waste any time
let's see how the first attempt at film
dumb went we open with the voyages of
the starship Korbel as we see it doesn't
have a very long run it's actually
crimsoning the new Starship Enterprise
as retire Captain Kirk and whichever
cast members would work for scale show
up to give their blessing I just want
you to know how excited we are to have a
group of living legends with us on our
maiden voyage I remember reading about
your missions when I was in grade school
oh really you're my hero
I'd like you to meet the helmsman of an
enterprise P ensign de Moura Sulu
it's a pleasure to meet you sir my
father's told me some interesting
stories about you yes like how he
originally wanted to be the captain of
the Excelsior in Star Trek 2 but you
wouldn't let him uh how you didn't show
up to Gene Roddenberry's funeral that
was pretty douchey on how you're just an
all-round great big prick it's a
fascinating read when did he find time
for a family finding retirement a little
lonely are we you know I'm glad you're
an engineer with tact like that you'd
make a lousy psychiatrist I can
contractually obligated to like you so
as they go out on their first trip just
for a routine test run
there's say it with me now I'm neutral
all they're the only ship in range they
don't have a proper necessity so they're
going anyway I have trained you well so
it looks like an intergalactic tapeworm
is threatening to ships as Star Trek
proves once again that anyone who is not
Captain Kirk is a pure incompetent
except for these guys but let's face it
the kids Kirk's ass all the time
Captain Kirk I would appreciate any
suggestions you might have already put
it first move us within transporter he
will speak more than tear us apart risk
is part of the game you sit in that
chair why do we let anyone anywhere do
anything without safety Kirk they get
close and beam up as many of the
survivors as they can one of them is
being played by Malcolm McDowell good to
know Curt Saints the one who would just
end up killing him in the end
antimatter discharged directly ahead
might disrupt the field long enough for
us to break away but there's some
technobabble that needs to be resolved
so Kirk goes down below to partake in
what Star Trek does best
then porn we're clear you get a cure but
you too Captain Kirk
Captain Kirk please respond hey Scotty
this is Captain Kirk saying I'm Chuck
Hoff meet me up on deck 15 so they say
that Kirk has gone where most cast
members want him to go before and we cut
two years later we see our new crew of
the enterprise on the holodeck still the
most improbable of Star Trek conventions
as we see that partaking in the HMS
pinna Wharf that's retract plank not
remove I must confess I am uncertain as
to why someone falling into freezing
water is amusing oh it's all in good fun
baby I do not understand Oh data you've
only been here 12 seconds and already
your bid is old do something unexpected
Deden that was not funny oh no you want
unfunny wait until he gets the emotion
ship that's right there's an emotion
chip in this movie a device that well
it's pretty much humanity and a hunk of
metal which data now feels he has to put
in seeing how he did the unspeakable
crime of pushing someone into water so
yes you could say that his gross burned
from getting a woman way the Captain
Picard then finds out some devastating
news that he decides to keep from most
of the crew looks like the observatory
took quite a beating
will you begin an investigation I'll be
in my ready sir make it so just do it
boy
dodging responsibilities being totally
emotional and illogical he's acting like
a real boss but they do find one
survivor though malcolm mcdowell his
character who we saw years before Saren
dr. tholian sorry what no Lord of the
Rings clip what me for the four years
I've been doing this show I played every
single clip from the lore the Rings
movies well great now am I supposed to
do oh um ever notice how the Sauron here
sounds like the Sauron from the x-men
comics that was only around very briefly
don't know how many of you remember that
it had to be pretty hardcore to get that
reference
but that's not important we have datas
annoying emotion ship to exploit I
believe this beverage has produced an
emotional response it looks like he
hates them
oh yes I hate this it is revolting more
please I guess it wasn't too bad as long
as they don't exploit it anymore no Tony
I have not okay sesame yeah they go on
with this for a while very funny mr.
tri-corner I love it can I help myself
okay this will slip in the Ruff
Schneider chip cuz I swear I'm ready to
smack them just see if you can help me
give these panels over will you make it
so okay somebody please up the
badassness of this movie
thank you McDowell so Sora fight for his
research and data chickens out because
of the emotion ship but a Klingon ship
appears and beams him out while also
attempting to kidnap Geordi yeah I know
big shock Geordi gets kidnapped in Star
Trek I'm sure they put him in a holding
cell with Robin April O'Neill and
Princess Peach they start a poker game
in every dungeon but while that's going
on we do find out why Picard is so
bummed out you never met my brother and
his wife did you know well they're so
opinionated
very junk what's happened burn to death
in the fire mmm
yeah pretty heavy stuff to lay in the
first Star Trek next generation film I
wouldn't mind so much except that it's
made even stranger by the fact that they
were only featured in one episode are
rarely referenced and even here we just
get a few sideways pictures all its kind
of hot to devote so much time to this
one really we know so little about them
how are we supposed to get emotionally
connected to characters that we never
see in the movie or only reference very
briefly I mean shit well one second
hello oh no my mother's uncle's nephews
fathers brothers sisters cousins sons
grandfathers great aunts niece just died
feel bad for me so we find out that
Sauron is teamed up with the Duras
sisters a duo of Klingon terrorists who
are helping Sauron out with his plan in
exchange for his deadly weapon designs
only one other person knows what Sauron
is looking for and it turns out it's
that chick from Theodore Rex he just
cares about getting back to the Nexus or
some exes it's a doorway to another
place that we call the Nexus
what happened to you it was like being
inside joy oh I had a feeling what they
did behind the scenes on the view but do
they see caught you if you go you're not
gonna care about anything all you'll
want is to stay in the Nexus well if
you'll excuse me I'm off to find the
Nexus sounds freaking awesome so the
captain and data tried to figure out
where Sauron is heading using a room on
the ship that they've never used before
and will never use again but it looks
cool however data is having trouble
handling his emotions I cannot continue
with this investigation are you having
some kind of malfunction no sir I simply
do not have the ability to control these
emotions part of having feelings is
learning to integrate them into your
life data them no matter what the
circumstance odd you will not be
deactivated got an officer onboard this
ship and I require you to perform your
duty just like the duties I dodged
earlier because of my emotional matters
but I'm the captain and in the end there
so they find out that saurons going to
wipe out a star to change the direction
of the Nexus to make it come towards him
wiping out all other life inhabiting the
planets in that solar system they make
their way there but the Duras sisters
threaten them with hostage journey I
can't trust them for all we know they
killed Geordi they might kill you too
we did not harm your engineer and return
it connects change or what me I will be
your prisoner but first you must be me
to the surface so that I can speak with
solemn well consider it a prisoner
exchange so really with no plan in mind
they beam the captain down to the planet
to talk to Sauron while they beam Geordi
back to the ship is there an amount of
time he's gonna stay down there couldn't
the enterprise just beam him back later
seeing how they're more powerful is
there a reason the uniform suddenly
don't match it nothing's adding up
oh it was terrible they tried forcing my
name to Toby
so Picard tries to reason with Sauron
while it turns out geordi's visor has
been bugged with a camera so they can
figure out where's the best point to
penetrate their shields for God's sake
nobody checked him out beforehand I
can't go through airport security
without having my balls touched and yet
they never inspected this guy who just
came off an enemy ship giving up our
freedoms my but but hey at least it puts
data in a better mood and you find a way
to scan for life-forms I would be happy
to sir
I just love scanning for life forms life
you tiny little life phones you precious
little life it's sing a long time again
this I the internet sing life works this
side sing row row row your boat tiny
little life to life go to everybody sing
along I said sing along I'm not
continuing to review unless you do what
do you guys do cut to commercial
Diggs so it seems Sauron has placed a
force field around his missile that's
going to blow up the star uh here's an
idea um why don't you beam him inside
the force field that shouldn't be too
hard number one but he still tries to
talk about destroying the star in order
to get to the Nexus in the end time is
going to hunt you down it's part of the
truth of our existence but if I told you
I found a new you know Sauron I think
you're making it more complicated than
it needs to be blowing up stars killing
people destroying planets you know where
the Nexus is going
could you just save up your money and be
like shadow please my god that was easy
hello Nexus how are you hey is
everyone's common sense in the Nexus too
but the sisters figure out how to
penetrate the shields and attack the
enterprise who quickly tries to look for
a way out plasma coil be susceptible to
some sort of ionic pulse perhaps
yes yes we sent a low-level ionic pulse
it might reset the coil it triggered the
cloaking device yeah yeah I can't
understand it either I'll just sum up
what it always is data can we blah blah
blah the technobabble baby if we yadda
yadda yadda there's a chance at oh boo
MIDI booty it's very unlikely that a toe
homina homina but we'll give it a shot
and of course it'll work
All Hands brace for boo Madiba money so
they pull off the homina homina and the
sisters are now defenseless roll the
explosion from Star Trek sticks to save
money
engage now partaking a funny line for
the trailer yes and we have our
McDonald's commercial yes McDonald's
Star Trek meal available for your kids
now so Sauron continues to listen to
Picard pester him hey here's an idea
lower the force field and shoot him but
he does eventually find a way through
and try to stop him
yeah you know you should have done only
the force field and shoot him but even
bigger problems are happening the ship
was hit bad and they have to separate
the enterprise in order to survive yes
be sure to move the children you always
bring on this constantly attack shap of
peace you know if I so much as heard of
Clan say a bad word I take my kid off
but in hindsight we do see the real
tragedy in office chaos dude girls bear
oh oh she doesn't go back for it we
never see it again
it's not even referenced they just felt
was really important to show that a
little girl lost her bear oh the bear
manatee oh my god there he goes there
goes the bear oh my god goodbye bear
goodbye all the casualties of war well
bury him next to Balzac now to be fair
the ship separating is not only a cool
scene but it also leads to one hell of
an awesome crash these are some of the
best effects in Star Trek history
well that wasn't such a charnel was it
don't play no ran that out I guess see
more movies but Sauron does destroy the
star and the Nexus comes right at him
and Picard they get sucked into it as
the rest of the enterprise of the planet
get blown apart we then see that the
Nexus is in fact Patrick Stewart doing
another rendition of Christmas Carol oh
come on guy the tickets aren't selling
anymore
no it turns out the Nexus brings to life
whatever your deepest dream is and the
cards is that his family is back to life
and totally happy but a shadow
whatever that means of Whoopi Goldberg
is there to tell them that it's not all
real and that he has a chance to still
go back and save everybody well as I
said time has no meaning here so if you
leave you can go anywhere anytime all
right I know exactly what I want to go
to the mountaintop on Veridian 3 just
before Solan destroyed the star what why
there why don't you go to where you
first picked him up or when you decided
to first go out there in the first place
fuck watch you go back and send your
brothers family while you're at it
what's the shit about being put back in
the moment you already know you lost it
what are you a moron did everyone's
brains just impede out of their heads I
have to stop him but I need help yes the
most physically fit fighter the world
has ever known or lame jet yeah that'll
work
I'm wondering do you realize do you
smell something burning by the way I
know a great place that does toupees
looks like something was trying to cook
some a it's alright it's my house at
least it used to be I sold it years ago
so yeah as we pretty much partake in
somebody's fanfiction but cartels Kirk
what's going on this isn't really your
house we are both of us caught up in
some kind of temporal Nexus
do make up on dill we in the cabin
behind the oregano behold two of the
greatest Starfleet captains of all time
Mickey a only one other thing to top off
his epic herring of Awesomeness tolls
ladies and gentlemen toast oh my god I
just soiled myself
so definitely kind of a strange setup
but it does lead to some interesting
conflict
Kirk acknowledges that he wants to stay
in his perfect past got a Starfleet
officer you have a duty I don't need to
be lectured by you
I was out saving the galaxy when your
grandfather was in diapers you're in
diapers this time I'm gonna walk up
these stairs march into that bedroom
tell him tomia I want to marry her
remember all that stuff I said in Star
Trek 5 about needing your pain and how
we should embrace how it makes us who we
are
Oh to 180 I wish I slingshot around the
Sun years ago and pulled this off
hello Nexus I love the Nexus no
responsibilities I'm gonna like it here
truck starts to realize just how unreal
everything is and then no fear and no
remorse it's not always such a hot thing
because it isn't real come back with me
I'll be stuck son enough Spock were here
he'd say that I was in irrational
illogical human being for taking on a
mission like that spot was going to be
here but apparently they only gave him
two lines and so he said live long and
suck it that's my joke the first family
guys and Big Bang Theory and now you
critic oh come on there's enough memes
on the Internet what else am i stolen
from you well how about my voice for Big
Daddy key to movement well it's not like
you really need the residuals or
anything got me there
so Kirk and Picard go back and try to
stop Sauron together
you do realize that if you never go into
the Nexus you'd never be able to come
back and do this properly and here's
another thing it looks like things are
going awry why don't they just let
Sauron continue with his plan and let
the Nexus hit up they can just go back
and try it again
can't they hell they can do this for all
eternity if they wanted until they get
it right it's not like anything of major
importance is lost this time around just
Captain Kirk get away from that launcher
I just wanted to go to the Sun
so Kirk is lying under a bridge dying as
he says his final words we made a
difference oh my
that's right captain james t kirk with
his very last breath did in fact do it
george takei impression oh ma you win
georgie you win so he buries him under
some rocks not sure they get him later
or anything and the shuttle comes to
take the card back to his ship oh it
will be good to see the ship once again
on damn it
number one I gave you two orders while I
was gone don't blow up the ship and
don't sleep with anything I thought the
latter would be more probable but as we
look through the wreck data finds one
survivor that he holds very close to his
heart
spot spot so the ship is destroyed but
the trek lives on as they beam
themselves out and make their way back
to space dock Godfather that's what you
call me so to beam up
by the way did I tell you I met Jim Kirk
Latta
he's under a bunch of rocks geeks are
gonna complain about it for years
so that Star Trek generations it makes
no sense and it really is the biggest
problem of all I can overlook some of
the annoyances as it does have some real
good powerhouse scenes later but the
plot threats are so nonsensical that it
really does distract it's all over the
place and parts are good some parts are
bad I'm glad I saw it but it could have
been a hell of a lot better but hey on
the plus side Star Trek month is almost
over I only watch Star Trek when we left
to review do you know what that means
oh my god cameo I haven't seen it at all
isn't that fantastic knowing god no
bitching about the little tentacles that
nobody cares about them no talking about
all the dumb little things that I don't
give a shit it's all coming together and
it's not gonna happen but there's gonna
be no quick car cameo at all do you hear
me no lingering cameo
you tiny little life-forms